what if godzilla was in the scp universe
this has been a question in our minds
for quite a while and we will begin
with a little bit of intro into the
g-man for those who are more into scps
than kaiju's
this giant monster is the most famous
and fictional creature to ever exist
other than dragons
he came into the movie screen 66 years
ago in 1954
and since then this reptilian monster
has terrorized
and also saved humanity more times than
any other creature combined
anyway so if he was in the scp universe
how would the secret organization there
classify him and would he be perceived
as a threat or more of a benign guardian
that would be left free to roam and
protect but before we
go into depth into the topic we also
have to introduce the scp
to the kaiju fans so what is the scp
this universe is about a secret world in
modern life where there are different
organizations like the foundation
the goc the church of the broken god etc
which rush to try and find and contain
anomalous objects or creatures called
scps
the scp or secure containment protect or
also
the special containment procedures often
simply refer to as the foundation
it's a secret organization dedicated to
the security and safety of the world
by securing and containing all of these
anomalous and hostile artifacts
or entities in this strange universe
there are giant monsters and also
entities that defy the laws of physics
in size and abilities
so the monster vs titans or if they were
to exist
would certainly be classified as scps
but what kind of monsters are there in
the scp universe
well there there exists a multitude of
creatures and monsters are both small or
tiny and also gigantic and some of the
largest creatures in fiction
for example scp-096 is a humanoid entity
that is human size who kills anyone that
has seen his face
another example is scp 3700 1 and 2
which are gigantic monsters that battle
each other in north sea
twice a year during spring and autumn
while scp-3000 is a very long more eel
called anatha sesha residing in the bay
of bengal of the coast of india
and has a body length of 600-900
kilometers
scp-2764 is a massive biological entity
of unknown origin
its height measures to be approximately
382 meters tall
and is estimated to weigh over 150 000
tons
and it is found in antarctica so will
godzilla be classified as an scp
well let's look into that on what he is
the king of the monsters
is a giant creature born of radiation
and sometimes as a hyper-evolving
creature
and also as an ancient super species so
his origins
have a proper explanation but most scps
don't have that
this kaiju however is truly gigantic in
size with his biggest incarnation
standing over 300 meters
or 1000 feet tall in its godzilla earth
form
and most of us titanic's gojira is
standing over 120 meters
or 4 feet tall just by that alone he is
eligible to be classified as an scp as
his size
is unnatural with the biggest normal
animal the blue whale being only 100
feet long or so
so if we take that into account and
alter his powers he will definitely be
classified as a dangerous
scp entity what about the other titans
and kaiju's
touhou and the monsters have brought in
a multitude of monsters and kaiju that
differ in design
origin size and abilities with some
being very familiar like the
like king kong who has an overgrown ape
and others like ghidorah which is an
extraterrestrial tree-headed dragon is
very strange and also some like rodin
which is basically a gigantic pterosaur
they will definitely be classified as
scps and also dangerous at that
but kong and mothra might be in another
group
probably a safe or a helpful scp it's
all in the imagination for this
and this brings up another excellent
question as to what class of scps
will they all be in so in the scp
universe there are three main classes
which are
safe euclid and keta and there are also
explain formal neutralize and napoleon
save class scps are anomalies which are
easily and safely contained
euclid class scps are anomalies that
require more resources to contain
completely where containment isn't
always reliable
keter class scps are anomalies that are
exceedingly difficult to contain
consistently or reliably with
containment procedures often being
extensive and complex
thormel class scps are anomalies that
the foundation uses to contain
or counteract other scps or anomalous
phenomena
other classes like neutralize which
means the same as its name
and napoleon which represents an
immediate threat to human life
are kind of rare so let's try and
classify the different kaijus and titans
as scps
godzilla of course will be a killer
class as he would be near to impossible
to contain even with special weapons and
procedures
next mothra she would be somewhere in
the safe and thormial classes as she is
benign
and helpful in many ways to humanity and
come to think about it
godzilla from the monster verse would
also be a formula class entity
as he helps in containing the other
titans as well as defeating existential
threats like ghidorah
and immutos corn would also be a formal
and safe class entity rodan ghidorah
destroyer and the others would all be
classified as kida
and at times as a napoleon class since
they would be an immediate threat to the
world
now that we have established the classes
of scps that the titans and kaiju are in
and godzilla as an apex
monster in his own right would
definitely come into contact with other
giant scps as well as smaller ones
so what if godzilla faced off against
another giant scp
which ones would he dominate against and
which ones would he not be able to
defeat
entities like the siren head the giant
mori eel scp-3000
and leech boy would be a hard match but
he would eventually succumb
to the powers of the g-man the eldritch
antarctic which is a reality warping
entity would end
in a never-ending fight or a stalemate
as neither would be able to defeat the
other
scp-3700 1 and 2 are also extremely
powerful ones that reappears every half
a year
so there's always going to be another
fight with them
so let's see the scps that godzilla
would not be able to match up against
the first being scp-2317k or the
devourer of worlds
standing over 200 kilometers tall and it
is entirely covered in overlapping plate
like scales
it is an end of the world entity and
nothing was able to kill it or
neutralize it
the second entity is scp-169 of the
leviathan
this one is between two thousand and
eight thousand kilometers in size
and therefore any attack by godzilla
would not have any profound effect
on it since the damage would be tiny in
relative to its scale
and the most powerful attacks of
godzilla the nuclear pulse can only
annihilate things within a few
kilometers radius
but this is like a tiny static shock to
the leviathan
the third entity that godzilla would
lose against is scp-001
or the gate guardian which is impossible
to contain colossal entity that stands
over 1 000 feet tall in height
with many wings and a flaming sword
scp-001
can and would annihilate any and all
beings organic or artificial
that pass within a one kilometer radius
of itself and ignore its warnings
and this is down to the sub-atomic level
the speed at which these attacks happen
make it look like scp-001
barely even moves ranged attacks of
scp-001
end with instant annihilation of all
projectiles including nukes
and attackers no matter where they are
in the world so godzilla has no chance
with this one
now that we have properly assessed
godzilla's ranking in this universe
there is one question that arises
isn't the scp foundation and monster
verse monarch
somewhat of a similar kind of
organization well both
are extra national agencies that work
above the normal rules of conduct for
any other groups or organizations
and both of them contain dangerous
creatures i mean one is more equipped
than the other
the foundation has the support of all
the world's governments
and can break any law it sees fit for
the greater good of humanity
but monarch isn't that far behind
although it's still
subjected to the us government senate
hearings and stuff
anyway if you want to discuss more on
this then the comment section is down
there
below and with that we come to the end
of this video
do like and subscribe and also share it
with your scp
or kaiju friends but most of all do
smash that notification bell for regular
updates on future videos
till then take care fam and stay safe